oh
no
come on apple what's going on today i'm
gonna answer all of the questions that
the other reviewers didn't answer about
the m1 ultra mac studio in our previous
video you saw how vadim and i took apart
the mac studio showed off how it comes
apart all the insane components inside
the dual sided heat sink with those fans
some other findings such as the
upgradable and socketed
ssds a lot of interesting info but today
we want to see just how it performs i
want to look at the thermal performance
the fan speeds and the noise can it
thermal throttle if you're doing both
cpu and graphics tests just how fast is
in certain situations and why in the
world is the gpu not performing as well
as apple advertise we're gonna look at
the frequencies we're gonna look at the
wattage and we're gonna talk about
things that other people just don't
wanna dig into so let's go ahead and get
started now as you guys could see right
here we have the studio display i'm
putting out a video on it tomorrow
seeing if it is worth it comparing it to
lg's ultra fine 5k so make sure you guys
are subscribed and of course you know
that we bought three max studios we sent
over 17 grand we're gonna give you guys
the best mac studio content on the
internet now the first thing that i want
to check out is the thunderbolt ports
you know we have six of them but can you
really maximize all of them so i'm gonna
go to the system report here we're gonna
go down to thunderbolt and take a look
at that right there
we have six thunderbolt buses in the
past you'd have two thunderbolt ports
just like on the
mac minis and macbooks but it would all
actually just be one controller so they
have to split the bandwidth here we have
six dedicated ones each one can actually
be split into three if you want to this
thing is insanely powerful now this
model is the one with 64 graphics cores
and along with that it also has
128 gigabytes of ram so this is the big
boy it's not the one that i took apart
now if you're curious about that one yes
i did get it back together it does work
just fine but just to make sure
everything's good this is the one hasn't
been touched as far as thermals but we
will be comparing this 128 gig to a 64
gig and now it has 48 graphic scores i'm
personally curious to see
does 64 really matter what if 48 is
almost as fast that's what we'll be
answering in the future now the next
thing i want to do is test out this ssd
all right look at that 5850 and 5145
oh it just reset right there uh nice and
quick actually slower than the macbooks
but that might just be because these are
non-soldered to the motherboard there's
extra delay there but this is still
insanely fast now inside the mac studio
we have two beefy fans and we downloaded
tg fan pro here to see what the fans run
at and it's very interesting that even
at idle even when we're not doing
anything the fans actually spin up above
their base
1100 rpm as you guys can see so they're
running about 1300 when they don't need
to be
now we can actually go ahead and max out
this fan and see what the loudest these
can go that's one thing nobody's shown
anybody it's 3 500 rpms but how loud is
that
okay we hit max it is spinning up
all right
i don't know if you guys can hear that
that is actually pretty dang loud let me
pull this over here
okay there you go
that is moving some air guys
3 500 rpm
we know that this system can get pretty
dang loud and i'm gonna see what happens
when we actually max out the cpu and gpu
can it keep it cool enough because we
have
64 graphics cores and 20 cpu cores let's
switch that back to system
bam now it is silent and another thing
people didn't really show are thermals
now a lot of applications out there they
will lie to you they won't give you the
right info including tg fan pro but we
have another program here i statistica
that is working correctly
and looks like we're at 29 degrees
celsius right now for our cpu and 30 for
the gpu cluster also memory down to 17
celsius for one of the banks that is
insane now a lot of people have ran
geekbench so we know those scores but
what they haven't done is actually tell
you what the cpus are running at and the
load on the cpu so let's go ahead and
run geekbench it's going to start out
with the single core test looks like
we're peaking at about 16 watts and bam
the multi-core kicks in
61.2
watts right there so the max studio is
definitely giving the cpu as much power
as it needs for all those 20 cores
literally maybe even more than double
than what we get with an m1 max in a
macbook pro and our thermals look at
that our hottest cpu core is at 34
degrees that's set for the hottest core
some of these are at 29 still
no issues at all the fans are still just
at the lowest temp that they've run out
very impressive and look at that peak
wattage 84.
84.36
watts okay
so that means that apple is actually
allowing this thing to hit higher when
it needs to now overall score
it's amazing kills the 28 core mac pro
uh but a little bit lower than what i've
seen online i think i've seen 24 000
single core is not bad as well now a lot
of people are complaining about very low
metal scores compared to even the mac
pro and definitely compared to nvidia
graphics cards uh so i want to show you
guys why this is happening not only
people are talking about this in
geekbench 5 for this compute score it
does all of this so dang quickly that
the graphics doesn't even have time to
properly ramp up so right now we see we
got a peak of 53 watts the m1 max should
be able to hit up to 60 at the maximum
this should be able to hit up to 120 at
least the way they designed it and apple
showed off on stage 105
but look at this it literally only
peaked at 53 watts so geekbench is not
utilizing the full performance of the m1
ultra now we still almost got a score of
105 000 beating out the vega 2 in my mac
pro and that was a 2 800 graphics card
so that is good but this is not its true
performance so let's go ahead and close
down geekbench 5 and i will show you
what this can actually do and how much
power the gpu can use and at what
frequencies it runs
with 3dmark's wildlife extreme let's go
ahead and start their unlimited tests
we'll also take a look at the
temperatures for the graphics bam look
at that we're at 83.45
watts
running and
whoa
dang that was fast that was really fast
okay
the ammon ultra average 212 frames per
second that's about 76
better than the m1 max in the 16 inch
macbook pro which my best score was 121
so not double but it is close to that
three quarters of the way there of
course this was just such a short burst
and what's interesting to me is that the
gpu only hit 83.45
watts i don't know if it only needs that
for this or how quick it was or what
but technically based on the design to
get the full performance we should be
running at about 120 and based on
apple's graphs 105. so what i want to do
now is let's go ahead and just close
this down i'm going to run the extreme
stress test which is gonna just keep
hitting this machine uh for about 20
minutes we'll see what kind of power
usage we get how hot the system gets in
the fans if they even need to ramp up
all right guys we are having an issue
with the m1 ultra
look at the wattage 55 60
44 watts why are we not maxing out this
gpu and a lot of times we're not running
at 300 megahertz pegged like we would on
an m1 max i'm seeing this going down to
1100 1249 1253
in our wattage uh right now 51 63 64.
why are we not pushing this
harder we literally just need tougher
tests
because i can't run this and get it to
hit the system all the way so we're
gonna figure out what we can do for that
but let me go ahead and cancel this
let's go ahead and test out the cpu we
know that cinebench is going to max this
out of course we've already seen some
scores for cinebench but nobody's talked
about the power usage frequencies and
temperatures let's start our 10 minute
test and right away our cpu is
going full blast all right guys we are
rolling and we're averaging about 57 58
watts right now on the cpu peaked at
71.3 so at least we're getting a good
proper cpu scaling now it should be
60 61 but it looks like we're maxing out
the cpu completely 100
not doing shorter bursts in this case we
are not running consistently at uh
pretty much where we want to be and if
we look at the the performance cores you
guys could see that it's running at
3.0
megahertz not 3.1 or 3.22 like we saw in
geekbench those are just the peaks apple
is not running this ship at 3.2
consistently when they could let's look
at temperatures 48 degrees celsius guys
an intel 12 gen would be like 95 right
now
if it's just maxing out its performance
getting close to what this does slightly
faster if you got a good cooler we are
literally running a 48 49 degrees
celsius right now let's take a look all
right we do have some cores that are
hotter
this different this time around 58
degrees celsius guys that is
insanity
we said that when the m1 mac mini was
running at 70 degrees celsius for the
performance core 7275
that was shocking
look at this
look at this bad boy man
53 degrees celsius right now on the
hottest core that is incredible and our
fans
look at this guys
literally
they don't care
they have not moved from their regular
idol uh range actually slightly lower is
that 1350 before
so
literally you can have the m1 ultra the
best cpu you're maxing it out it's ready
for three minutes
it doesn't care now why isn't apple
giving us more performance why can't we
run this at 3.5 come on guys at least
3.2
that would be nice like the m1 will run
at 3.2 in the m1 mac mini apple they're
limiting this chip that's why we're not
getting perfect scaling not because
there's issues literally it's just apple
look at we have tons of headroom
everywhere
they're the ones holding it back okay so
we're almost done we have 13 seconds
left out of this 10 minute stress says i
have never seen a computer act this way
we're at 55 degrees celsius the fans are
still at idle it just does not care even
my mac pro
heated up more than this after the
stress test what did apple do with this
cooler
they just went crazy all right guys we
got 23
919
slightly lower than what other people
are getting but once again i'm running
multiple different software in the
background this power metrics custom
program it's constantly pulling data so
it's using a little bit of cpu power
which is why we're just slightly below
but just about like 24 100 or so is what
people are getting
that is killer that has no issues at all
way better than i expected i'm gonna run
that again but what i want to do is for
those of you guys that are worried about
fan noise i've had multiple people
actually reach out to me
and say hey you know is the m1 max just
a lot quieter because you know you have
less cores and whatnot let's see what
happens when we have both now uh
obviously it didn't care before cpus
right now
running at full blast let's kick in the
gpu as well all right that ran and it
didn't care at all all right we gotta go
that's the wildlife unlimited okay
that's not the extreme one no that is
the extreme one let's try out gfx bench
instead guys i don't hear anything there
at all let's look at the temp 62 for the
cpu
what's the graphics at
uh 51.50
geez louise this system does not care
and our fans were still
at idle maxing out the cpu and maxing
out the gpu and we got a score of
484
that's the same exact leak that i saw
earlier of course they weren't maxing
out the cpu at the same time
this is just insane maybe we're gonna
have to throw some red footage at it and
export in lightroom in order to get more
usage now the cpu is impressive the
cooling system is very impressive but
the graphics is where i'm a little bit
underwhelmed especially because it's not
using its full potential so we have the
latest version of blender that was just
released let's go ahead and go into a
system we're going to select metal here
perfect we got the m1 ultra gpu selected
it may be faster using both but let's
try it out just using the gpu i'm going
to go over to our cycles engine
gpu compute bam let's render our party
tug scene all right we are rendering
here and look at this guys
our gpu is running at 27
to 30 watts uh here we have 100 usage
1296 megahertz maxed out here this bar
goes further though maybe because it's
the m1 ultra i don't know but why are we
only using
30 watts of power
this should be a up to 120 watt uh gpu
about 105 based on apple's charts this
is incredible the nvidia graphics cards
fly
through this render here and look i mean
this bar should be all the way up here
if we were using it correctly the 16
inch m1 max laptop does this in about a
minute and 52 seconds compared to a
minion 18 for this desktop
that costs at least five grand if you go
for the 64 core option
it's a minute 18 here
i don't know guys i have to say that's a
bit disappointing and seeing how little
power it's using has so much more
capability
hopefully this software just needs to
have a lot more optimization so that i
could be a lot more competitive with
on you know the computers on the windows
side so let's go ahead and just close
this down now the main reason we bought
a mac studio with the m ultra for
ourselves to use long term is video
editing we put out six seven videos a
week and we have to sit and wait for
export time so if there's anybody that
can benefit from having double encoders
and decoders that is us so let's see how
long this five minute 4k project takes
bam i started the timer right there all
right guys we are only using seven watts
of the graphics for the cpu
we are at what is this over here i can't
even find it anymore it's way too late
it's been a long day
and
the 13 of the cpu 35 of the gpu here of
course we have those dedicated decoders
and encoders and bam
oh
no
why is this
come on apple what's going on
a minute and 17 seconds
the m1 max
60-ish maco pro does this in a minute
and 22 seconds now i can only think of
two things
one some of the tests we've seen online
and some of the bad results that's just
what it is we don't have good scaling
with the m1 ultra at least what apple
wants you to think you're gonna get or
two we need some software updates now
when the m1 macbooks came out
we had an update right away that
actually increased the clock speeds and
got a better performance and when these
macbooks came out we surely right after
got an update as well
uh that helped and here we have no
updates whatsoever we're at 12.3 the
only update i'm seeing is just for this
display to fix some bugs with it
uh and with that as well if you take a
look at final cut we're running version
10.6.8
i went to the app tour see if there's an
update no
that is the latest version which was
released four
months ago
and to make matters worse if we look at
apple's
little fine print here where they gave
us all the nice sounding numbers how
fast it was
they were testing using the pre-release
final cut
10.6.2
apple
why is that not released
when this machine
has been released you know the testers
have had it for a week we just got it in
in the past you'd always get the updates
right away to make sure you're getting
proper performance
but no
and now this mac studio for at least for
this test
is barely faster than this macbook pro
which costs half the price with the
battery the keyboard the trackpad the
display
my goodness okay well maybe i'll still
perform great with tougher tests you're
gonna throw a lot tougher tests we will
have to test that out i'm excited to see
how the 48 core version performs that
one is a thousand eight hundred dollars
less than this configuration right here
and the m1 max for 2 grand
compared to this laptop it might perform
better at a really good price so i'm
very excited for our upcoming videos
make sure you guys click that circle
above to subscribe so you don't miss it
out check out our teardown if you
haven't seen it yet or
or just the other video there and we
will have a comparison of this studio
display compared to lg's all future find
if it's worth it guys super excited for
all the videos we have coming out make
sure you guys won't miss out on those
this with max and i'll see you in the
next video